♪ ♪
>> Greg: BEN & JERRY'S HAS A
NEW ICE CREAM FLAVOR DEDICATED
TO THE RESISTANCE UNLIKE THE
RESISTANCE, IT CONTAINS NUTS.
I KNOW.
HERE'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF HOW
THE LEFT INJECTS POLITICS INTO
EVERYTHING.
REMEMBER WHEN POLITICS STAYED IN
ITS UGLY LITTLE LANE?
NOW IT'S ALL OVER THE PLACE.
IT'S IN MOVIES, SPORTS, YOUR
DESERT.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
DECIDE THAT THE PERSONAL IS
POLITICAL.
YOU CAN'T ESCAPE IT.
LOOK AT THE LABEL.
MAYBE IT'S ME, BUT I PREFER NOT
TO BE GLARED AT WHILE EATING
ICE CREAM.
I GET THAT AT HOME WITHOUT THE
CURTAIN.
THANKS TO THE LEFT, KEEPING
POLITICS OUT OF REGULAR LIFE IS
SEEN AS COMPLICIT TO EVIL.
IF YOU DON'T JOIN OUR MAD
CRUSADE, YOU ARE THE PROBLEM
TOO.
I BET THIS STUFF TASTES GOOD BUT
WHO CARES.
THE COMPANY SAYS THAT BY
PURCHASING THIS GLOP, YOU WILL
BE SUPPORTING "GROUPS WHO ARE
FIGHTING PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
REGRESSIVE AGENDA."
BUT THEY SHOULD ADD WHILE ALSO
ADDING TO YOUR DEADLY OBESITY
BECAUSE ISN'T THAT WHAT BEN &
JERRY'S DOES?
THEY SPEAK CALORIES TO POWER.
ACCORDING TO THE NIH COME
OBESITY AND BEING OVERWEIGHT
LEADS TO 300,000 DEATHS PER YEAR
IN THE U.S.
THAT IS SECOND ONLY TO SMOKING.
THE MESSAGE IS SIMPLE.
IF OBESITY KILLS THAT MANY
PEOPLE A YEAR AND I SCREAMING
TOO OBESE, HOW LARGE A ROLE DOES
BEN & JERRY'S PLAY IN THIS?
AREN'T THEY PART OF THE PROBLEM?
THEY ARE LIKE OVERWEIGHT
MARLBORO MAN.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY THEY PLAY UP
THE ACTIVISM.
THEY WANT YOU TO THINK THEIR
HEART IS IN THE RIGHT PLACE AS
THEY ARE BUSY CLOGGING YOURS.
JUDGE, THIS DOESN'T MAKE ME WANT
TO EAT ICE CREAM.
I LIKE IT TO BE FUN.
A >> Judge Jeanine: I HAVE TO
CONFESS I LOVE CHERRY GARCIA.
I WENT FROM THE ICE CREAM TO THE
BEN & JERRY'S YOGURT.
HERE'S SOMETHING FOR YOU.
I'M NEVER EATING IT AGAIN.
WHY WOULD THEY ALIENATE ME?
WHY GO OUT OF THEIR WAY TO
ALIENATE PEOPLE WHO ARE GIVING
YOU MONEY?
MAYBE YOU DON'T NEED MY MONEY.
GOOD.
>> Jedidiah: WHY WOULD YOU
MARGINALIZE HALF THE COUNTRY?
PEOPLE SAY THIS POLARIZATION OF
PRODUCTS REALLY WORKS.
BEN & JERRY'S HAS BEEN SO
POLITICAL FOR SO LONG.
THEY ENDORSED BERNIE SANDERS.
THEY ENDORSED SAME-SEX MARRIAGE
IN VERMONT WITH THE SPECIAL
ICE CREAM FLAVOR.
IF IT WASN'T FINANCIALLY WORKING
FOR THEM.
YOU KNOW YOUR ICE CREAM.
I FEEL LIKE THEY WOULD KNOW THAT
IF IT WASN'T WORKING.
PEOPLE SAY THIS WORKS.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK PEOPLE
PAY ATTENTION.
ONE OF THESE GROUPS HAS LINDA
SARSOUR INVOLVED, A NOTORIOUS
ANTI-SEMITIC, HAS SET AWFUL
THINGS ABOUT PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: THEY HAVE ALIENATED
HALF THEIR CUSTOMER BASE.
IN ORDER TO MAKE THIS FUN, I'VE
CREATED MY OWN ICE CREAM
FLAVORS.
ANTILIBERAL FLAVORS.
ABOLISH I.C.E. CREAM.
PETER STRZOK CHOCOLATE.
MOOCH TRACKS.
>> Juan: [LAUGHS]
I DON'T THINK SCARAMUCCI IS
GOING TO APPRECIATE THAT.
>> Jesse: NOUGAT GINGRICH.
SECOND AMEND MINT.
CROOKED AND CREAM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: HOW ABOUT CARAVAN-
CARAVAN-ILLA.
JUAN, ARE YOU GOING TO GO BUY
THIS ICE CREAM?
>> Juan: I LOVE IT BUT I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE FLAVOR IS LIKE.
>> Greg: PECANS.
PECAN.
HOW DO YOU ANNOUNCE IT    -- PRO
HOW DO YOU ANNOUNCE IT    -- PRN
HOW DO YOU ANNOUNCE IT    -- PRE
IT?
>> Juan: I HAVE A QUESTION
ABOUT THE MONOLOGUE.
WAS THAT A SPOOF?
>> Greg: 300,000 PEOPLE DIE A
YEAR FROM OBESITY.
>> Juan: WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO
SAY ABOUT PAPA JOHN'S?
HE IS A RIGHT WING NUT.
HE SAYS HORRIBLE THINGS.
>> Greg: I DON'T EAT PIZZA.
THERE ARE DIETARY ISSUES WE
CAN'T GET INTO HERE.
[LAUGHTER]
I USUALLY -- ICE CREAM FOR
BREAKFAST.
>> Juan: JUDGE, BECAUSE YOU
ARE A FAN OF BEN & JERRY'S, I
THE YOU SHOULD GET A VAT OF
CHUBBY HUBBY FOR YOUR FRIEND,
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT IS
MEAN.
DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO BE
DANCING ON ELECTION NIGHT.
A >> Greg: THIS REALLY IS
THEIR PENANCE.
THEY ARE CONTRIBUTING TO THE
DEATH OF PEOPLE.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT YOU WERE
JOKING.
ICE CREAM CONTRIBUTES TO THE
DEATH OF PEOPLE?
>> Jesse: YOU ARE THE ONES
THAT SAID TAX CUTS WERE GOING TO
MAKE PEOPLE DIE.